I loved going back to huggles of course
I did
it looks very familiar to anyone who saw
the ponte movies but obviously the
teaching staff are different
those names the stories the histories
that sit in the back of our mind from
the Potter series begin to weave their
way into beasts I have some questions
for you
Dumbledore actually be shooting here at
Lake Hawk where three of the films are
shot it's quite amazing really when I
walked on and saw all the trunks and
Hogwarts stickers and things like that
it's amazing it's like the ultimate
childhood fantasy into play witches and
wizards but it was slightly odd
out-of-body experience because I've
watched with everyone else
those classes it's only to be in it
you're in there doing it but then you
look back on as yourself and realize how
special it was go ahead and you too
ridiculous I felt quite sentimental
going back to homes
[Music]
[Music]
I'm scared
professor dumbledore everyone is scared
of something ridiculous yes you're next
that's an unusual one what mr. Scamander
fears above everything else is having to
work in an office sir go ahead and use
ridiculous
[Music]
magic rooms
[Music]
only in rare souls still win was
sculpting shadows
[Music]
cuz the old ways serve us no longer
I take it we've heard the rumors of all
television but he would rise to
dominance over the Wizarding World
so you're asking me to help hunt him
down
I can't move against Grindelwald it has
to be you in your shoes I'd probably
refuse to there's light
good evening it come on
[Music]
you underestimate your talents missus
come on
their arrogance is a key to our victory
muggles are not blesser
not disposable
yes you could meet you never met a
monster you couldn't love three days
mr. Scamander do you think tumble to
will known for her
[Music]
are you goats
no I'm alive well I'm an alchemist and
therefore immortal oh you're gonna fly
man
Jake 100 you don't look a day over 375
[Music]
you